these are drugs that you often read
about being misused at scale i mean the
misuse is the problem right yeah
no matter what the drug is yes
and that's actually what you're pushing
for is education and it should be it
should be legal and should be good so
people should know what's the difference
between um
proper use
positive use and misuse
i mean one public figure who has been
going through this is jordan peterson
he's been public about his struggle of
getting off benzos the withdrawal he's
going through i mean what are your
thoughts about
um
the misuse of benzos or opioids and so
on they have an epic epidemic that
people talk about
yeah i don't know
jordan's specific case but certainly
with benzodiazepines in general we
talked about withdrawal earlier when i
said that with alcohol withdrawal you
can die so benzos and alcohol they're
closely related so benzoyl withdrawal
too can kill you
just like alcohol so when we think about
the effects that
benzodiazepines produce think about the
effects that alcohol produce they're
comparable or similar and so i know
that it's a difficult one to uh wean
yourself off if you develop the
dependence but we we we have uh
protocols for that
and i hope he's okay
interesting to see we have protocols for
that but from my understanding was that
like the protocols aren't standardized
it feels like
a lot of doctors aren't as helpful as
they could be in this process like it's
a bit of a mess
certainly with withdrawal they're more
standardized than anything so
like if someone is going through alcohol
withdrawal there is a standard protocol
that most physicians in this business
they follow and the same is true with
benzo withdrawal but the thing where it
gets murky is when they're treating
addiction itself so when you're thinking
about
the substance use disorder in the dsm
not just withdrawal but the entire
addiction that's where you have this
sort of uh
uh
divergence or uh diversity diversity in
terms of approaches and many of those
approaches are rubbish
what uh can you just elaborate
like technically what the term addiction
means that you're referring to when i
use the term addiction i'm referring to
uh the diagnostics this statistical
manual of the american psychiatric
association number five now the dsm five
that's never been wrong right oh
no
i'm just kidding oh you're right
that's a that point is well taken and
your point is that um um
their definition of substance use
disorder that's addiction that's what
i'm talking about but that definition
continues to evolve and so you're right
um they still
are working it out we're getting new
information from scientific studies and
so forth and so it's supposed to be
incorporated into the dsm but uh there
are some problems with the dsm like for
example um
they also have this sort of once an
addict always an addict thing and
there's no evidence to support that
um
but it's evolving and it's the
definition
that people in science and medicine use
and so we all know we're talking about
the same language when we call someone a
substance use disorder per patient or
someone who meets criteria for addiction
we all are speaking the same language
we're not saying that simply because
this person used heroin they are an
addict that's not what we're saying you
have to meet these criteria where you
have
disruptions in your psychosocial
functioning that's one and two
you the person are distressed by this
these this
these uh disruptions so people have to
meet those two basic criteria before we
say they are addicted
so once an addict owes an addict this
idea
uh so i've
i mean some of it is always mapped to
the person all right but i've just
the people i've interacted with who have
struggled with alcohol addiction i don't
know if what the proper term is
it seems like with alcohol anonymous
the process of
putting that addiction behind you
is a very very long process it's
surprisingly long to me that almost
seems like a whole life like it's not
always an addict but it takes decades
it seems like uh
what is that
what
can you maybe just
from your understanding as a scientist
from your understanding as a human who
studies human nature why does it take so
long to treat
to
to to deal with that
uh addiction well you you cited alcohol
anonymous right and so
i don't think of alcohol anonymous as
like a
a treatment that i would send any
relative to you know like for a drug
related problem you know i think
alcohol anonymous aaa is really good for
um social interactions um making sure
people um
have a social group and they have peers
i mean that's a good thing we all need
that social interaction
but i don't think they know much about
drugs that's not that's a it's like
saying uh
well you know my uncle broke his knee
and he he has his support group and they
said this um
and then we follow that uh that doesn't
make any sense but in our society
judges even sentence people to go to aaa
are you kidding me
but but that's the kind of thing that
has been allowed to happen in this
society because we think of drugs
as does moral failing or drug drug
addiction as is moral failing um and any
idiot can provide treatment and
no disrespect to aaa because i think
what they do
is a lot more than what some people do
because at least they have the social
these social interactions you have a
social group
that's better than what a lot of these
other idiots out here do
well in that social support group
unrelated to the drug it helps cure some
of the environment issues you might be
in that's the whole point absolutely so
we kind of coupled the drug to the
environment but the reality is as as you
argue
most the problems come from the
environment certainly with people who
are experiencing drug-related problems
with most of the people not all but most
there are differences
uh like that psychedelics
and uh like psilocybin has versus
alcohol i personally think
uh you know i've enjoyed both
experiences in different ways i
is it possible or is this are we getting
into the realm of poetry
to describe the benefits like how it
alters the how the different drugs alter
the mind
and the places it can take you that
produce a positive experience yeah
no it's very real you know like
some drugs
take people in places that other drugs
can't and that's that's very real
i have friends uh some of them you know
they um
they for example say that they've never
had an experience like the one they had
with ayahuasca and they've done a number
of sort of things um
but they did the ayahuasca in a setting
with
a shaman and
this group and
they felt like
they actually began to heal or solve
some problems that they were trying to
solve for uh some years and that's
that's great that's great for them um
and nothing else does it for them like
that and that's absolutely fantastic um
all i
argue is that um
if that kind of thing happens for you
with ayahuasca facili with psilocybin
with some other
psychedelic
why isn't it possible
that heroin does that for someone or
cocaine does that for someone else or
mdma does it for someone that's it
that's interesting to imagine like a
shaman for heroin
like why not
and or cocaine you said creating an
environment for yourself for use of
these different substances and that
environment has a
as a very
uh strong impact on the actual
experience that you have
but i mean so um
cocaine is an upper
and then yeah the way we define drugs
like uppers and
downers that's a that's a really uh
kind of inappropriate way but it's a
quick way but so we certainly say
cocaine is an upper or stimulant yes but
um
you know it depends on the activity of
the person before they take the drug say
like if you're like really active before
taking a drug like cocaine it might
actually calm you you know so it all
depends on the activity of the person
before they take the drug i remember uh
i don't know if you know matthew johnson
is of course
he did all these studies on or
i remember just reading a paper i didn't
get a chance to talk with him much about
it but it was about condom use
and cocaine
and then you know what like the doses
and whether people are more less likely
like the unsafe thing there
is the
using or not using or not using i guess
uh condoms during
sexual intercourse i don't know i just i
love that these drugs that have
connotation probably because of
hollywood negative connotations are
actually being studied by science and
the actual impact they have and what are
the negative effects again in those
studies often
the positive effects
are difficult to quantify i think maybe
i guess you can from self-report and so
on but effects are not difficult to
quantify
you ask people about their euphoria
uh you can see how well people are
getting along like in our studies that
we have people
uh sometimes in groups and you see how
well they get along um on the various
drug conditions or placebo conditions uh
it's really
it's not that difficult
you